حسنًا ، لقد قمنا جميعًا بمسح
كل شيء على مدار العام الماضي
وشهرين
الآن للتطهير ، لكن الآن تقول CDC أن
الخطر
الفعلي لانتقال Covet 19 عبر الأسطح
منخفض جدًا ، أعني أن السؤال الأساسي بالنسبة لك
هو
هل  هذا يعني أننا يجب أن نتوقف وماذا
يعني أنني أعني غسل اليدين على
الرغم من
أنني أتخيل أنه لا يزال شيئًا مهمًا
نعم
لا ، لذا فأنت تعلم أن الأمر استغرق عامًا ، أعني
هذا أنك رأيت نوعًا ما كيف
يتقدم العلم هنا أحيانًا ببطء
ولكنك تعلم حقًا فهم  كيف
ينتقل هذا الفيروس ، هل
سيتصرف مثل
نوروفيروس ، فأنت تعلم أن نوع فيروس ما قبل الجائحة
من الفيروسات الذي
ينتشر بسهولة على الأسطح أو حتى
فيروسات البرد الأخرى
التي تنتشر بسهولة على الأسطح في
البداية أعتقد أنه كان هناك الكثير
الحذر نحن لا نعرف كيف ينتقل هذا
بشكل كامل الآن نحن نعلم أنه لا يبدو أنه
ينتقل جيدًا على الأسطح
إذا كنت تعيش في منزل وكان
شخصًا ما على علم بالطموح في ذلك
المجرب المنزلي  لا تزال فكرة جيدة
لتطهير الأسطح ، ولكن بخلاف
ذلك
ليس هناك فائدة كبيرة هو ما يقوله القرص المضغوط
أيضًا إنه يستحق الإشارة أيضًا إذا كان بإمكانك الاحتفاظ
بهذه الصورة في رأسك ، فالفيروس نفسه
محاط نوعًا
ما بالدهون إذا كنت تعتقد
مثل مقلاة دهنية
تحاول تنظيفها ،
فلن تستخدم مناديل كلوركس ،
ربما تستخدم الصابون والماء ،
فكر في نفس المفهوم عندما
يتعلق الأمر بيديك ، لذا فإن
غسل يديك بالماء والصابون
حقًا ، ستكون
أفضل أسطح رهان لك
لم تكن أبدًا هي المشكلة المحددة
التي كانت تلامس السطح
ثم تلامس عينيك من أنف
فمك إذا كانت يديك نظيفة فهذا
سيساعدك في هذا ولكن أيضًا
الأنفلونزا وفيروسات البرد الأخرى
والفيروسات الأخرى بشكل عام